l und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich
am 15 Dezember Richard es ist wirklich
in ne Tagen ist Weihnachten ja und ich
sitze hier auch in mitten der
Weihnachtsdeko man braucht ja diesen Ort
wo aller Schutt abgeladen wird in der
Wohnung also jeder hat ja so manche
haben eine Schmuddelecke andere haben
eine
schmuddelkimmenate und genau da steht
hier stehen jetzt die ganzen
Verpackungen von den Weihnachtskugeln
und Tannenzapfen und so rum super ne
also nicht so dass hier nicht ohnehin
keinen Platz mehr wäre und Geschenke und
so hast du alles klar hast du alles
schon ja das da bin ich mit da mache ich
mir sehr früh und rechtzeitig also bei
den wichtigen Leuten wirklich ja bist du
so ein so ein Plan ein logistikgenie was
das angeht na ja also eine Form der
Logistik besteht darin nur relativ
wenigen Menschen was zu
schenken allen anderen längs vereinbart
zu haben dass man sich ja ohnehin nichts
schenkt und dann kann man sich auf die
wenigen ganz gründlich konzentrieren
Richard viel passiert wir hatten
Jahresrückblick war sehr interessant mit
unter anderema sens zu sprechen die Frau
des ukrainischen
Präsidenten die auch mal ein bisschen
berichtet hat das Wenige was sie
berichten darf da gibt's ja ganz viele
sicherheitsrelevante Themen aber was das
mit so einer Familie auch macht ne äh
und gerade wenn es auf Weihnachten
zugeht es ist am Ende völlig egal wer du
bist auch wenn du der ukrainische
Präsident bist wir alle wollen am Ende
einfach gute Eltern sein die ihren
Kindern schöne Weihnachten machen wollen
weißt du es ist ganz egal wer wie alt
sind deren Kinder weißt du das ich habe
mich nicht damit beschäftigt um offen zu
sein aber die können nicht so alt sein
die beiden sind
ähm 45 Jahre alt glaube ich beide 45 45
46 beide äh sie war Autorin für ihn
glaube ich der der war ja ein sehr
bekannter komedian wenn du dich
erinnerst in der Ukraine und sie war
Autorin und die haben sich sozusagen
klassischerweise am Arbeitsplatz
kennengelernt genau und dann und dann
wirst du plötzlich gegen jede Erwartung
wirst du plötzlich Präsident und dann
passiert das und plötzlich bist du
sozusagen die zentrale Figur auf die es
ankommt und wenn man sich mit der
Geschichte beschäftigt und sich noch mal
überlegt welche Rolle dieser Mann
eigentlich spielt und damit auch Sie und
damit auch die Familie für dieses Land
ich muss sagen es beeindruckt mich schon
wie wie wie wie klar dieser man da ist
und da da zeigt sich auch echter
Charakter wie wie war deine Woche
Richard du hattest
ein ich habe dich am Sonntag gesehen
im im zweiten deutschen Fernsehen zu
später
stundech genau haben wir ja schon das
ein oder andere Mal auch im Podcast
erwähnt genau ich liebe das mit Ivan
krassev zu sprechen weil das Spannende
an Gesprächen mit ihm besteht immer
darin dass er so so unbestechlich auf
die Welt guckt ne das ist das was ich
natürlich so häufig vermisse also dass
jemand mal hingeht und einfach mal
beschreibt was er sieht nicht gleich
wertet ne der hat mit Sicherheit auch
seine persönlichen Wertungen aber die
die leiten seine Analyse nicht also er
guckt auf das Weltgeschehen ne das große
Thema ist jetzt die Veränderung der
Weltordnung allmähliger Abstieg der USA
der Aufstieg Chinas der Aufstieg Indiens
insgesamt starker Bedeutungsgewinn für
den globalen Süden ja da haben wir schon
häufiger drüber gesprochen die
Weltordnung verändert sich zu einer
multipolaren Weltordnung und er
beobachtet das so ne der hat ja auch so
ein bisschen was Gemütliches ne hat
einen großen Schalk auch im Nacken und
beobachtet ja beobachtet jeder zweite
oder dritte Satz enthält immer eine
kleine Ironie oder versteckte genau und
dann guckt er sich das Weltgeschehen an
und versucht einfach mal so genau wie
möglich zu beschre schreiben also was
ein guter Wissenschaftler ja auch tun
sollte was da so ganz ganz genau
passiert und das erlebe ich immer sehr
erfrischend weil die meisten Menschen
mit denen ich sonst darüber spreche die
haben von Anfang an immer eine starke
Wertung na also die gehen mit einer
Wertung in die Analyse rein also als
erste steht schon mal fest wer die Guten
sind und wer die Bösen sind und für wen
man ist und gegen wen man ist und wie
man die bewertet und dann kommt dann aus
dieser Perspektive häufig nicht so eine
klare Analyse am Ende dabei raus sondern
eigentlich nur eine besteh dessen wie
man das vorher gesehen hat ja und das
ist das schöne wenn man dazu lernen will
dann muss man mehr Abstand zu den Dingen
nehmen und das ist der große Reiz von
Gespräche mit Ian i KR das Bulgarin ne
bulgarischer Politologe der glaube ich
in Wien lehrt genau und der ja der
gerade eine Studie rausgegeben hat
zusammen mit zwei anderen Hochkarätern
Mark Leonard Englisch Politologe und
Timothy Garten Ash den werden auch viele
unserer Hörer kennen ne ja den wir auch
schon häufiger mal zitiert haben hier
weiß nicht ob den schon mal in seiner
Sendung hattest aber großer
Politikwissenschaftler der vorzüglich
deutsch spricht auch in Deutschland eben
sehr berühmt und populär ist und die
haben mal etwas gemacht was mich
wirklich sehr interessiert hat das war
auch der Grund warum wir krassev
eingeladen haben wir haben eine Studie
gemacht wie sehen eigentlich die
Menschen so global gesehen die Welt wir
haben ja schon sehr häufig immer wieder
darüber gesprochen wie sehen wir
Deutschen die Welt vielleicht auch
Europäer wie sehen wir beide die Welt
aber jetzt mal einfach drauf zu schauen
wie sieht man aus wie als Südafrikaner
auf die Welt oder als Ägypter oder als
Brasilianer oder Inder Chinese Pakistani
Türke auch europäische Länder natürlich
und dann haben sie das alles mal so
versucht zu sortieren mhm und da kam in
so hinblicklich der großen
weltanschaulichen Fragen enorm spannende
Antworten aus also meine schöne
Nachricht für aus der Perspektive des
Westens ist
die allermeisten Menschen in der Welt
finden dass wir hier in Europa oder in
USA ein ziemlich gutes Leben haben
finden das auch zum Teil besser als das
Leben was sie in ihren Ländern haben was
einen auch nicht wundert ne sind auch
sehr viel arme Länder dabei aber die
sagen also was wir natürlich total
großartig finden ist der Wohlstand in
der westlichen Welt ne das ist super und
dass ihr auch noch Freiheit habt und
euer Leben sehr individuell gestalten
könnt F auch alle gut so das ist die
positive Seite und jetzt kommt das
überraschende jetzt würde man ja denken
wenn das die Grundauffassung der
Menschen ist dann müsste jetzt der
zweite Schritt folgen und sagen deswegen
setzen wir wir uns als Russen dafür ein
oder als Chinesen dafür ein oder als
Angehörige eines afrikanischen States
dass möglichst viel davon auch bei uns
realisiert wird und das kommt überhaupt
nicht als Antwort sondern dann kommt
eine Antwort die zunächst wahnsinnig
verstörend ist die sagen ja wir finden
das zwar gut wie das bei euch ist aber
ihr habt keine
Zukunft eure liberalen Demokratien
passen nicht mehr langfristig in die
Zeit
und in unseren Ländern ist das alles
ohnehin nicht
durchsetzbar also das sind beides also
zwei
[Musik]
sze die zum Nachdenken anregen also
erstens wie kommen die darauf dass wir
keine Zukunft haben ja das ist die
spannende Frage ich sehe das auch ganz
anders übrigens um das schon mal zu
sagen und das zweite ist warum halten
sie das so grundsätzlich in ihren
Ländern für unrealistisch mhm dann auch
z.B interessant das ist jetzt eine
weitere Schlussfolgerung ist dass sie
sagen in den großen weltpolitischen
Konflikten ja
ähm da muss man sich nicht entscheiden
ob man jetzt beim russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ob man
jetzt auf der Seite Russlands steht oder
auf für wen bist du die Frage stellt
sich für die allermeisten überhaupt
nicht sondern die die allergrößte
Mehrheit der Weltbevölkerung die gefragt
wurde sagt die sollen so schnell wie
möglich Frieden schließen auch unter dem
Preis dass die Ukraine Gebiete abtreten
muss das ist ja z.B auch eine Meinung
die völlig konträr ist zur
Mehrheitsmeinung bei uns und da fragt
man sich auch wieder wie kommen die da
drauf und erstens ist der ukrainekrieg
für sehr viele Menschen in der Welt
unwichtig ja wir sagen immer ein Krieg
Grenzen Grenzen verschieben in Europa
ist bei uns ein riesenargument als
Europäer grenzenverschieben in Europa
ist für einen Afrikaner überhaupt kein
Argument nee ja und für jemand aus
Ostasien und aus Südamerika auch nicht
das ist für sie gar keine wichtige
moralische Kategorie das heißt die sehen
also diesen Konflikt ich würde mal sagen
im weitesten Sinne als großen
Regionalkonflikt aber nicht als die
große globale Krise oder eine der zwei
drei ganz großen globalen Krisen das ist
also auch interessant zu sehen es ist ja
ein ein ein ein kleiner zwischen Ruf
dazu Richard wenn man sich mal mit
diesem Jahr beschäftigt wir wir haben
Gaza wir haben die Ukraine wir reden von
den zigtausenden und zehntausenden Toten
die es da gegeben hat wir sind entsetzt
darüber dass es z.B in in Gaza und die
Zahlen verdichten sich allmählich zu
einer Zahl mit Substanz im Sinne von das
wird ungefähr hinkommen in nur 7 Wochen
sind in Gaza so viele Menschen
Zivilisten ne Zivilisten gestorben wie
in der Ukraine in fast zwei Jahren ja ja
in 7 Wochen also die die Frage der
verhältnismäigke relativ hoher
Prozentsatz von Frauen und Kindern so
genau und das heißt über die Frage der
Verhältnismäßigkeit wird dann gestritten
und das Entsetzen darüber ist so groß äh
ich hatte in dieser Woche auch so einen
ein Moment diesbezüglich weil ruderich
Kiesewetter den ich sehr schätze
Sicherheitsmann der der der der CDU der
selber auch mal in der Bundeswehr war
und so weiter
der sagt ja das Verhältnis ist ungefähr
wir sprachen über diese
Verhältnismäßigkeit und das Verhältnis
sei ungefähr 1 Z 30 würde man so sagen
und ich ich sagte wie jetzt 1 Z 30 der
ja 1 Z 30 also man sagt für einen Toten
hamasterroristen sind wir bereit
ungefähr 30 Tote palätinenser genau in
in Kauf zu nehmen und und ich ich komme
über diesen ich ich weiß dass es das
gibt und ich weiß auch dass Militärs so
denken dass ist die Logik von Militärs
das ist auch die Logik von Menschen wie
Putin und anderen nur wenn du das mal so
hörst D dann also da geht's dir kalten
Rücken runter es ist das Jahr 2023 und
wir machen einfach mal so eine Rechnung
auf das ist eine Rechnung das ist aber
keine Rechnung sondern das das Sterben
ganze Familien hast du auch in diesem
Jahresrückblick gehört da war ein junger
Mann aus Berlin der auf
Verwandtschaftsbesuch in Gaza war und
als dieser Krieg losging und saß auf
diesem Podium da im Gespräch mit mir
gemeinsam mit einer jungen Frau aus
Israel die bei diesem Festival in der
negelfwüste gefeiert hatte und die die
unglaubliche Geschichte erzählte wie sie
sich mit ihrem Mann und ein paar
Freunden in einem Wohnwagen verschanzt
hat ich meine du weißt wie dünn die
Wände von Wohnwagen sind und die lagen
da über 6 Stunden drin sie war selber
sehr lange Zeit für die Armee tätig also
jemand mit Nerven wie Stahl und es muss
auch so gewesen sein weil sonst hätten
die
die wären sofort ums Leben gekommen ich
meine feuerst du eine Maschinengewehr
Salbe ab auf diesen Wohnwagen und dann
bleibt da drin kein Mensch am Leben
logischerweise die diese Terroristen
greifen diesen Wohnwagen an Schießen auf
dieses Schloss dass es da gibt so so ein
Vorhängeschloss und und versuchen das
Ding sogar anzuzünden und so weiter und
a einem Grund den sie selber bis heute
nicht beschreiben kann überleben die
alle da drin und als sie rauskommen äh
und und sie die hat dann auch diesen
Schuldkomplex sie sagt oh Mann ich hatte
diese Wahnsinnsidee dass wir uns alle in
diesem Wohnwagen verstecken ich bin
schuld daran dass wir jetzt gleich alle
ums Leben kommen werden mit mit diesem
Gedanken im Kopf Haaren die da drin
sechs Stunden aus und dann geht sie
irwann raus und sie sagt undter lagen
hunderte hunderte toter Menschen so und
jetzt sitzen diese beiden Menschen die
diesen Horror aus beiden Perspektiven
jetzt kennen und erlebt haben sitzen da
bei mir in der Sendung und reden darüber
wie sehr sie das verurteilen beides wie
sehr sie sich wünschen dass man endlich
versucht friedvoll zu leben wie sehr sie
sich wünschen dass endlich die Politik
sich verändert weil sie sagen wir werden
von schlechter Politik immer wieder an
diese Abgründe
herangeeführt das hat mich wirklich sehr
sehr bewegt äh und das war so ein war so
ein Moment der dir dann auch mal den den
den ganzen Wahnsinn klar macht ne wenn
du über über über Krieg redest und über
dieses diese diese zynische Logik die
dahinter steckt ja es gibt eine eine
ganz eigene Logik von Kriegen es gibt
eine eigene Logik von Militärs und zu
dieser Logik gehört
ähm die gruseligsten und grauenhaftesten
Dinge zu versachlichen mhm und wir
brauchen gar nicht darüber zu reden wie
schrecklich das ist dass wir in einem
Zeitalter leben wo wir diese diese
beiden furchtbaren Kriege toben und
ich meine wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen dass auch noch viele andere
Massaker und Auseinandersetzung gibt und
dass die all die vergessenen Kriege über
die wir ja schon mal gesprochen haben
inau in Afrika oder genau der jemenkrieg
wo die Rede von über
300.000 toten Zivilisten ist und ein
Krieg der uns in unseren Nachrichten
eigentlich nie wirklich groß
interessiert hat obwohl mit uns
befreundete Nationen wie Saudi-Arabien
oder verfeindete Nationen wie der Iran
daran maßgeblich beteiligt sind genau
ich habe genau deswegen kam ich auf den
Gedanken eben weil du sagtest und da
kommen wir sozusagen zurück zum Thema
Perspektivwechsel als alles eine Frage
der Perspektive wenn du sagst a
afrikanischer Sicht ja ist das für uns
etwas von dem die Leute sagen na ja gut
also jetzt habt ihr das was wir
eigentlich ständig haben im Sudan ist im
April glaube ich ein Bürgerkrieg
ausgebrochen in diesem Jahr ja von dem
ich bis vor wenigen Tagen ehrlich gesagt
nicht also ich wusste irgendwie dass da
was ist aber dass da 10 000 Leute ums
Leben gekommen sind in diesem Jahr
mindestens Millionen vertrieben genau
Millionen Vertriebene und so weiter also
ich sag mal n anderes als das was in der
Ukraine und auch in Gaza stattfindet
aber da das findet nicht statt wir wir
reden darüber gar nicht eine Frage der
Perspektive ja es liegt a daran dass der
Krieg nicht in Europa ist es liegt B
daran dass wir ihn nicht als
Stellvertreterkrieg wahrnehmen ne also
die die Bedeutung des ukrainekrieges ist
einmal eben Krieg in Europa ne ein ein
über von einem Land auf das andere in
Europa ja nicht besonders weit weg
Luftlinie von Berlin ausgesehen und das
ist das eine was es für uns zwar nicht
zu einer moralischen Kategorie macht
aber was für uns natürlich einen
riesigen
emotionalen Wert hat und das zweite ist
eben dass wir es interpretieren als
einen Krieg
zwischen Autokratie und Demokratie oder
als einen Krieg äh Osten gegen Westen
oder wie auch immer wir wir wir da die
Bilder für suchen also wir sehen darin
etwas viel viel Größeres als nur ein
Angriffskrieg auf ein Land ist sondern
wir sehen darin quasi ein etwas was eine
enorme symbolische und zukunftsbedeutung
hat ob das alles so ist oder nicht
darüber haben wir uns ja auch schon mal
unterhalten da gibt es viele
verschiedene Interpretationen zu genau
aber auf jeden Fall ist es ein Krieg der
uns sehr sehr viel mehr bewegt als viele
andere Auseinandersetzungen ich fand
auch interessant was der der der
kenianische UN-Botschafter gesagt hat
der gesagt hat wenn man mal überlegt was
ihr für ein Bohai gemacht habt in den
Zeiten der coronapandemie ja wo es darum
geht Menschen leben um jeden Preis zu
schützen und zu machen und was weiß ich
was das hat er nicht kritisiert das hat
er nur g in welcher Relation steht das
eigentlich zu der Frage wie sehr er euch
um die Angelegenheiten des Klimawandels
in Afrika kümmert scheint euch auch im
Vergleich relativ egal zu sein wenn ihr
Menschen in der Sahelzone und in den
ganzen äh semiariden also
halbwüstengebieteteen südlich der Sahara
werden da alles verdort und die Menschen
sterben und vertrieben werden und
Bürgerkriege und Massaker ausbrechen und
so das scheint alles für euch keine so
riesige Bedeutung zu haben aber kaum
kriegt ihr mal eine mittelgefährliche
Pandemie ab ja und schon dreht ihr
völlig am Rad und das ist natürlich so
ne die die
Wahrnehmung man kann sagen es ist
huchelei und andererseits kann man sagen
liegt wahrscheinlich in der Natur des
Menschen und das er
abstuft zwischen sich den anderen und
den ganz anderen ja gibt ja diesen
schönen Satz von von krastev dazu ne man
spricht immer von der Heuchelei des
Westens aber leider haben wir kein
Monopol auf diese Heuchelei natürlich
nicht natürlich nicht jeder jeder sieht
das also Moral ist doch immer sehr stark
wie du gerade auch selber gesagt hast
eine Frage der perspek
ja vom eigenen Standpunkt aus blickt man
moralisch in die Welt und nicht von
einem übergeordneten Standpunkt aus der
sich darum bemüht die Sache so gerecht
wie möglich zu betre da muss ich gerade
an Annalena bererbock denken unsere
Außenministerin die jetzt Klimakonferenz
in Dubai auf einer
Pressekonferenz sagt was alles zu
geschehen hat und so weiter und sagt
aber da gibt es leider dieses beharren
der alten Kräfte und ich habe so ein
Moment gestutzt und dachte was was
denken die jetzt alle wieder wenn Sie
von uns hören dass sie alle so alte
Kräfte sind Western von gestern alle
oldschol und das wo sie uns selbst ne
als alte Kräfte sehen ist der Aussage
des kenjaners der gesagt hat ne also die
Zukunft sind wir ja was auch immer für
politische Systeme wir haben wir sind
ohehin die Mehrheit in der Welt und die
Zeit in der eine kleine Minderheit
US-Amerikaner und Europäer über die
Geschicke der Welt bestimmten kann in
Zukunft nicht erhalten bleiben genau ja
also für die sind wir das alte Eisen das
noch darauf har die Welt gestalten zu
können oder nach seinen Vorstellungen
einzurichten ich meine ich finde es geht
ja jetzt in diesem Moment wo ich das
sage nicht um moralische Bewertung
sondern es geht um verstehen das war ja
auch das was ich so reizvoll am Gespräch
mit Ivan KRAS finde einfach mal zu
erkennen wie sehen eigentlich die
anderen die Welt wie sehen die
anderenind eigentlich die Argumente der
anderen daran zu glauben dass unsere
Systeme möglicherweise also unsere
liberalen Demokratien keine Zukunft
haben
ja was ist der Grund und warum glauben
Sie dass es für ihre Länder eben nicht
so wichtig ist liberale Demokratien zu
werden obwohl diese ja in der
Vergangenheit so einen Wohlstand
angehäuft haben mhm das sind alles hoch
interessante Dinge da gehört ja z.B auch
zu man hat viel scheitern sehen man hat
ja viele Länder die demokratisch
geworden sind äh erlebt dass ich dann so
viele Vorstellung oder Wünsche die man
damit verbunden hat am Ende auch nicht
erfüllt haben ich glaube das spielt
natürlich auch eine nicht ganz
unmaßgebliche Rolle sind ja nicht alle
Länder die so nach dem Mauerfall
demokratisch und liberal geworden sind
haben sich ja nicht mustergültig
entwickelt dann wir haben auch viele
Gesellschaften mit harten Spaltungen
zwischen Arm und Reich erlebt und so
weiter also s sind ja nicht alle soziale
Marktwirtschaften nach dem Vorbild der
Schweiz oder Deutschlands oder
Skandinaviens geworden und man hat auch
erkennen müssen dass ob ein Land
erfolgreich ist oder nicht nicht
ausschließlich davon abhängt ob es eine
liberale Demokratie ist ne da ist eben
China das prägnanteste Beispiel dafür
dass auch diktatorisch regierte Staaten
wirtschaftlich sehr erfolgreich sein
können also du nimmst dir das
kapitalistische System aber sozusagen
bringst es ein in ein ganz anderes
System das mit mit unserer Vorstellung
von Demokratie nichts zu tun hat wir
haben immer gedacht Kapitalismus geht
nur erfolgreich in liberalen Demokratien
genau das haben wir uns ewig schön
getrunken wir haben immer g völlig klar
warum das nur in liberalen Demokratien
geht weil wir ja Fehlerkorrektur
brauchen ja der alismus muss lernen muss
zur Fehlerkorrektur möglich sein und
Autokratien werden Fehler nicht
eingestanden in Autokratien gibt es
keine Fehlerkultur ja ein Demokratien
gibt's eine Fehlerkultur die heißt
Abwahl also wenn Regierung
unerfolgreiche Politik machen kommt halt
die Opposition dran es gibt
Meinungsfreiheit im Form von Presse wo
unausgesetzt Kritik an falschen
Entscheidungen oder vermeintlich
falschen Entscheidung betroffen wird und
deswegen kann das nur in dieser
Kombination funktionieren ich fand das
übrigens ein ganz starken Moment habt ja
auch in der Sendung drüber gesprochen ne
als als krastev sagte es gibt einen und
deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt darauf
wie deine Argumentation da geht ich
teile diese These überhaupt gar nicht
dass unser System das der Westen dass
die liberalen Demokratien ja dass wir
fertig haben um einen berühmten
Fußballtrainer mal zu zitieren sondern
ich glaube dass wir eine große Stärke
haben und er hat sie auch beschrieben er
sagte dass es gibt eine Sache und darin
sind Demokratien unschlagbar gut die
sind langsam die sind bürokratisch die
sind mühsam es geht nichts voran der
Flughafen dauert ewig und so weiter und
die Bahn fährt auch nicht alles okay
aber im Gegensatz zu einem chinesischen
System beispielsweise ist eine
Demokratie in der Lage sich zu
korrigieren sich selbst zu korrigieren
und das machen anderen nicht Putin mus
sicher das stimmt ich find ich nicht so
sicher muss ich nicht selber Ken ne ich
meine bei den Chinesen also die
Korrektur das ist ja die Frage wo kommt
die dann her die Korrektur kommt eben
nicht bei uns daher dass jemand
abgewählt wird oder an den Pranger der
Öffentlichkeit gestellt wird oder
Entscheidung zurücknehben muss weil
falsch waren und solche Sachen sondern
die findet hinter den Kulissen statt ne
natürlich gibt es auch feh Fehler
natürlich ja natürlich also ich meine da
wird natürlich auch innerhalb der
politischen Kaste werden diese Dinge
diskutiert und da werden auch leute
leute unerfolgreiche Leute aus dem
Verkehr gezogen und andere Leute kommen
dahin nur alles nicht in Form eines
demokratischen Prozesses ne sondern
sagen wir mal China wird eher geführt
wie eine
Firma also so muss man sich das
wahrscheinlich eher vorstellen also wo
wo unerfolgreiche Manager abgesetzt
werden und durch andere ersetzt werden
ja aber dann komm diens auf den
hauppunkt zurück also ich teile ja deine
Ansicht auch wir sind nicht fertig ne
das ist überhaupt nicht das was ich
glaube aber wir sind in einer gewaltigen
orientierungskrise das glaube ich schon
und deswegen finde ich es auch
wahnsinnig gut dass wir uns mit den
Positionen der anderen beschäftigen
nicht weil wir die teilen müssen sondern
weil das als wichtigste ist erstmal
überhaupt zu verstehen warum und wie
andere Länder andere Kulturen auf die
Welt gucken wie die z.B darauf gucken
wenn wir den Begriff der Menschenrechte
oder unangenehmer von westlichen Werten
sprechend ja wenn wir das Einsetzen
westliche Werte z.B wird in dem größten
Teil der Welt als Kampfbegriff
verstanden und als nichts anderes und
das ist natürlich wahnsinnig schade weil
wenn wir westliche Werte sagen dann
benutzen wir den Begriff meistens gleich
bedeuten mit Menschenrechte und
Menschenrechte sind eine der größten
Errungenschaften der Menschheit
überhaupt mhm und ich würde also
jederzeit und immer und überall dafür
einstehen dass die Menschenrechte gelten
und dass es enorm wichtig ist auf die
Menschenrechte zu gucken sie zu
berücksichtigen und und und und und aber
wenn wir sie westliche Werte nennen dann
sind es keine Menschenrechte mein
sindere Werte und nicht die Werte der
Chinesen und nicht die Werte der Malaien
und nicht die die Werte der Peruaner und
so weiter dann tun wir so als wäre das
unser Besitz ja als wäre das was was
hätten wir so im Portfolio und das
wieten wir den anderen als Produkt an
mhm sondern Menschenrechte und das ist
ja gerade der Gedanke dahinter die sind
nicht westlich nicht östlich nicht
südlich nicht nördlich sondern sie
sollen für alle Menschen der Welt in
gleiche Maße gelten ja also diese Farbe
westlich die müssen wir sofort da
wegnehmen nur weil historisch
wesentliche Vorarbeiten dessen was wir
heute in der UNO unter Menschenrechten
definieren im westlichen Kulturkreis
geleistet wurden und weil es da auch
eine entsprechende Tradition gibt ist
doch das giftigste was wir machen können
denen das als westliche Werte
aufzutischen und gleichzeitig zu sagen
dass es für sie gelten soll mhm müssen
wir also viel vorsichtiger mit umgehen
ich würde den Begriff sofort streichen
und durch den Begriff Menschenrechte
ersetzen mhm du hast vorhin gesagt
Richard sehr interessant dass sozusagen
die die Idee ist wir wir oder die die
die ja eine eine der Thesen die man
häufig hört im Moment ja wir wir sind
fertig wir sind durch hier mich was
nicht Donald drumsfeld der damals auch
sagte ja diese alte Welt da in Europa
Kier das alte Europa genau nicht in den
Irak ziehen wollten genau so das Al EUR
gerichtet die checken nich genau da war
auch wieder dieser Sound ja ihr seid
krass sagt das ja auch das hat was damit
zu tun also das Gefühl jetzt kriegen wir
euch ja jetzt machen wir euch fertig
weil wir natürlich auch Alter Gesell en
sind ist auch demographisches Thema aber
gleichzeitig und das ist interessant und
darauf hat er auch in deiner Sendung
hingewiesen du sagtest selber von
krassev ist jemand der immer von ganz
oben ganz nüchtern so drauf guckt
darüber bin ich ja selber über diesen
Mann irgendwann gestolpert in diesem
großartigen Buch das Licht das er
lososch damit ist er ja so international
berühmt geworden und da da findet sich
diese ganz nüchterne Betrachtung als die
Mauer fiel gab es weltweit 16 Grenzzäune
heute sind es das Buch ist aus 20117
glaube ich 65 die entweder schon im
Betrieb oder im Bau sind ich würde sagen
jetzt sind es noch mal deutlich mehr und
auch die EU Außengrenzen die mal glaube
ich 2 300 km waren sind mittlerweile bei
ungefähr 2000 km angekommen also die
befestigten Grenzen heißt harte äh um es
in den Worten der EU zu sagen physische
Infrastruktur säune Mauern und alles was
dazu auch ein schöner Begriff physische
inf physische Infrastruktur wir wir wir
Schotten uns ab so ähm und genauso
nüchtern drauf geguckt hat er bei dir in
der Sendung gesagt wusstest du
eigentlich dass in den nächsten 14
Monaten 4 Milliarden Menschen das ist
echt viel bei verschiedenen Wahlen ihre
Stimme abgeben werden ich ich weiß nicht
wie man auf so einen Gedanken kommt sich
das mal anzuschauen aber es ist
natürlich wahnsinnig interessant ist
aber für mich der Hinweis darauf dass
offensichtlich diese Idee von Demokratie
und wir stimmen ab und das das Volk
entscheidet und so weiter dass dieses
System mit nichten am Ende ist sondern
ganz im Gegenteil W wenn 4 Milliarden
Menschen abstimmen dann scheinen sie ja
etwas an diesem System gut zu findinden
ja also erstmal ist das eine gute
Nachricht dass 4 Milliarden Menschen
abstimmen die schlechte Nachricht
dahinter ist auch in Systemen die wir
keine liberalen Demokratien nennen wird
gewählt und die das ist das das Spann
also wir wir sagen immer Demokratie und
Autokratie ne das ist bin ich kein
Freund von weil der Begriff Autokratie
ist das wo fängt Autokratie an wo hört
das auf die russische
präsidialdiktatur ist eigentlich ja fast
eine Diktatur ist aber formell eine
Demokratie eine Präsidialdemokratie wird
ja gewählt jetzt nächstes Jahr ne ja und
in ganz ganz vielen anderen Staaten
wahrscheinlich sieht in Kasachstan auch
ähnlich aus und in Aserbaidschan und wo
auch immer die Tatsache dass sich das
irgendwo gewählt wird heißt ja noch
lange nicht dass etwas eine
funktionierende Demokratie ist es gibt
da ganz viele Zwischenformen haben wir
auch schon mal drüber geredet Hybride
Formen ja und das Spannende ist dass
krassf gesagt hat das ist ja ein völlig
fließender Übergang er hat ja gesagt die
Grenzen zwischen Demokratie und
Autoritarismus ist die am wenigsten
bewachte Grenze der Welt
großartigerie bewachte Grenze das kann
man durch das unmerkliche Verschieben
der wasag wie nennst du das physischen
infrastrukturuktur kann man ein System
ja das wie eine Demokratie aussieht ja
völlig aushühlen also diese Staaten die
sieht a wie eine Demokratie ist es aber
nicht ja ist wahrscheinlich die
häufigste Regierungsform der Welt der
Satz ging ja noch weiter ne wir können
leicht sagen was eine Autokratie ist
aber wir sind nicht sicher ob wir sie
erkennen wenn wir sie sehen genau das
ist das was in Ungarn passiert ist ne
schon mal drüber gesprochen also das
sind einfach gewiefte Juristen am Werk
die genau wissen wo sie ansetzen müssen
wenn sie sozusag sagen dass dass das das
System aushölen wollen du drehst nur in
ein paar Schrauben und plötzlich hast du
ein System das sieht aus wie Demokratie
aber in Wahrheit läuft darauf hinaus
dass immer du zwangsläufig die nächste
Wahl gewinnst genau und das kann man nun
wirklich sagen ist die wahrscheinlich
häufigste Regierungsform der Welt also
papdemokratien Hybride Demokratien oder
anokratien ist auch ein schönes Wort ne
aus zusammengesetzt aus aus
Anomie ja und äh Demokratie auf der
anderen Seite das heißt also die die
eigentlichen
herrschaftsprozesse ja die finden
Jenseits Demokratie statt die Leute
dürfen wählen Sie wählen Politiker die
haben natürlich völlig unterschiedliche
Möglichkeiten Propaganda für sich zu
machen im Fernsehen oder in den Medien
oder die Medien so gleich zuus schalten
dass die Opposition gar nicht äquat zu
Wort kommt und so weiter und so weiter
und eigentlich Regieren in diesem Land
Oligarchien Geheimdienste das Militär
und das ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich
in dieser Form die häufigste
Regierungsform mhm aber noch mal zurück
zu zu der Frage ob wir fertig haben ja
also jetzt müssen wir mal auch nicht von
einem Modus in den anderen verfallen
also erst haben wir diesen Modus gehabt
wir sind die größten wir sind die Besten
an unserem Wesen wird die Welt genesen
alle werden genau wie wir werden alles
ist nur eine Frage der Zeit so das ist
der alte die alte Sicht jetzt die andere
oh Gott die Chinesen steigen auf die
Inder steigen auf der globale Süden wir
verlieren politisch ökonomisch an
Bedeutung wir haben fertig so und äh so
wie das erste äh eine völlig
eindimensionale Sicht ist ist es das
zweite auch das heißt wir haben
tatsächlich noch lange nicht fertig aber
wir müssen sehr klug sein der wichtigste
Begriff den krassev benutzt ist der
Begriff der
alakardpitik er sagt es geht heute nicht
mehr um China oder USA es gibt nicht
mehr dieses bipolare Schema ja die
multipolare Weltordnung die kennt
mehrere Zentren und Mächte und die
können alle in irgendeiner Form
miteinander zu tun haben und vor allen
Dingen auch all die anderen Länder die
Schwellenländer die afrikanischen Länder
die suchen sich nicht mehr das komplette
Menü aus ja Amerika Westen und so weiter
oder wie früher Sowjetunion Kommunismus
und so sondern man mit dem einen teile
ich das und mit dem anderen teile ich
das und mit dem von dem kriege ich
Rohstoffe und dem verkaufe ich meine
Produkte und so weiter und zwar völlig
ungeachtet der Frage was da für
ungssystem ist was da für eine Religion
ist was da für eine Weltanschauung hin
und das sagt er das bildet quasi das
Relief des 21 Jahrhundert und da ist mir
wichtig dass wir das erstmal tief sacken
lassen und begreifen dass wir aufhören
in dem Schema von Schwarz und Weiß ja
Systemkonkurrenz Demokratien gegen
Autokratien und umgekehrt dass wir nicht
in diesem Muster denken sondern dass wir
verstehen dass dieses Muster das
eigentlich aus der Zeit des Kalten
Krieges St
dass dieses Muster fürs 21 Jahrhundert
so nicht mehr passt sondern dass
unheimlich viele dynamische
Veränderungen drin sind und wir machen
das ja auch faktisch so wir handeln mit
lupenreihen Autokraten also gibt's was
autokratischeres als Monarchien ja und
kriegen wir unser Erdgas aus Qatar nicht
aus einer Monarchie handeln wir nicht
mit Saudi-Arabien einer Monarchie wir
berücksichtigen das ja auch in
Wirklichkeit gar nicht aber wenn wir
doch gar nicht nach dem Schema
Autokratie oder
die Welt einteilen warum behaupten wir
das ständig dass es darum geht also ich
das meinset mal richtig einzurichten um
dann gezielter und überlegter zu gehen
wie kommen wir ökonomisch zu unserem wie
werden wie müssen wir wertepolitik
machen wir sind ja Werte wichtig ne muss
ich ja mal ganz klar sagen ich gehöre
nicht zu den Vertretern der Fraktion die
sagen Werte spielen keine Rolle Völker
und Staaten haben Interessen diese
Fraktion die habe ich gefressen da
gehören Leute wie hen Kissinger zu wie
Gregor Gesi und wie Herfried Münkler
immer drei Leute die ansonsten keine
Gemeinsamkeiten haben zu nennen und es
stimmt nicht ich kann nicht auf die Welt
gucken und sagen Werte vergessen wir
jetzt mal wir gucken nur rein unter
interessensgesichtspunkten auf die Welt
wenn ich das mache Markus dann könnte
man sagen russische Angriffskrieg ja
entspricht ja ganz offensichtlich den
russischen Sicherheitsinteressen und den
russischen Machtinteressen ist in
Ordnung ich habe ja dann keine
Möglichkeit wenn ich keine Werte habe
habe ich überhaupt keine mög mehr zu
sagen was ich für richtig und für falsch
halte nein aber trotzdem trotzdem würde
ich immer sagen dass die drei die du da
gerade genannt hast an dem Punkt total
recht haben ich meine was ist es denn
anderes als Interesse schlichtes
deutsches Interesse wenn wir hingehen
nach Qatar und sagen okay jetzt machen
wir bitte mal aber LNG Lieferungen und
was ist es denn anderes als deutsches
Interesse wenn wir jetzt hingehen und
kaufen Putins Erdöl einfach über den
Umweg Indien ja und dann gerne
Markus ich wierspreche dir doch nicht
dass dasenspolitik machen nein und dass
wir vielleicht also ich mag die ehrliche
das ist für mich die die ehrliche
anagepolitik würde bedeuten weiterhin
das viel viel viel günstigere Erdgas aus
Russland zu beziehen das wäre noch viel
besser als aus Katar unter reinem
ökonomischenem Interesse was haben wir
davon profitiert dass wir so günstige
Gaslieferungen gekriegt haben das ja
auch die Argumentation der
wagenknechtpartei so da sagen wir aber
da sagen wir aber nee ne ne ne nee also
wir können ja mit jemand der hier
völkerrechtswiedrig die Ukraine
überfallen hat von dem wollen wir nicht
weiter das Gas beziehen also da spielen
plötzlich W Rolle wenn wir aber mit
Qatar und Saudi-Arabien wier sprechen da
ist von Werten dann nicht mehr die Rede
weil wir ja unsere Interessen verfolgen
müssen können wir unser Wertesystem
nicht mal ein bisschen vereinheitlichen
und das mal ein bisschen auf die den
Stand des 21 Stand des 21 jahrundert
bringen ja ich k es einfach ganz einfach
drehen und sagen na ja gut also auch bei
der Ukraine geht's in Wahrheit um das
würde ich ja nicht bestreiten noch mal
Markus ich bestreite
nicht interz witig Interessen sind
absolut wichtig ohne Zweifel die Frage
ist ob es nur um Interessen geht weil
wenn es nur um Interessen geht dann kann
ich die Verhaltensweisen anderer Staaten
auch Aggressionen völkerrechtsbrüche und
so weiter nicht mehr verurteilen weil
ich sag ja ist halt
Interessenspolitik also irgendwo habe
ich doch eine wer ich ver de Gedanken
wenn ich wenn ich die Kürze und sage es
geht nur um Interessen dann ist jede
politische Sauerei gerechtfertigt wenn
sie einem Interesse dient ja ich würde
würde trotzdem sagen auch die drei eben
von dir genannten die haben wenn du
sagst im Hinterkopf gibt's da irgendwo
ein Wertekanon den haben do aber die
haben immer ein Spaß daran wenn jemand
von Werten redet ja dann so zu lächeln
und so ein so so ein Blick zu machen so
ein Wissenden Blick als hätte man gerade
weinbrandpraline im Mund ja sich so
zurücklehen und so sagen nach dem Motto
du klein Doi mit plüchor du glaubst noch
an Wert ja ja ja obw selber wie Du
völlig zurecht hast auch Wert im
Hinterkopf haben weil wenn sie keine
Werte hätten dann hätten sie überhaupt
keine
Beurteilungsgrundlage das ist aber das
was ich sagen will also sozusagen die
völlige Entzauberung von wertepolitik
ist nicht die Lösung ja du hast schon
recht das klingt dann immer so als würde
man ein rosainhörner glauben und so
weiter und jetzt kommen wir gerade mal
aus dem aus dem Märchenwald und gerade
aus dem philosophischen Seminar und
hätte keine Ahnung vom Leben und so
weiter ja ja das stimmt wobei ich ich
mag das wenn Leute klar und gerade
aussprechen und ich mag es auch wenn sie
provozieren und und und sozusagen ein
dann ma dem Pot setzen dann kann man
sich ja whren man könnte sich z.B damit
wehren das ist doch spannenderweise und
das finde ich nämlich großartig Dinge
gibt wo unsere Werte und unsere
Interessen sich zu 100% Decken z.B z.B
darin dass wir alle Menschen auf der
Erde ein sehr vitales Interesse daran
haben zu überleben und dass unsere
Kinder und Kindeskinder das auch tun
also eigentlich wäre ja Klimapolitik
etwas was unsere Werte wir müssen die
Umwelt schützen ja und damit uns selbst
schützen Wert und unsere Interessen wir
wollen überleben ja wunderbar zusammeng
gehören mm also eine Politik die sich
daran interessiert und fragt wo haben
wir denn die Punkte wo die Werte und
Interessen überall in der Welt mehr oder
weniger die gleichen sind da mal
anzusetzen das find ich viel spannender
als bei Werten immer nur über das zu
reden was uns trennt und nicht über das
zu reden was wir teilen mm noch mal
zurück zum Thema Richard ne gibt ja
sozusagen diese diese Idee diese
Erzählung und das wird ganz ganz häufig
od das auch häufig in der Sendung die
Amerikaner das erodiert alles seit dem
Beginn des 21 jahrhunderts sortiert sich
quasi die gesamte Welt neu und so weiter
die Welt ist nicht mehr wie im Kalten
Krieg durch die Konkurrenz zweier in
übrigens Europa erfundener Systeme
geteilt und so weiter also so ähnlich
hat all POS neulich meine ein sehr guten
Stück beschrieben wo er sagte die die
die Idee dieses globalen Südens gibt es
die eigentlich wirklich ja und und der
liefert auch das zentrale Argument haben
wir auch schon paar mal drüber geredet
hier die große Mehrheit der
Weltbevölkerung wird ja schließlich von
Ländern aus dem globalen Süden
repräsentiert und so weiter und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt mal lernen mit
geringeren Ansprüchen zurecht zuukommen
und und diese alte internationale
Ordnung die gibt es nicht mehr das ist
der Abgesang sozusagen auf uns und
Posener schreibt dann so herrlich das
hätte die Hamas gerne dass wir das so
sehen das hätten die mullas in dereran
sehr sehr gerne das hätten auch die die
Taliban in Kabul sehr sehr gerne und das
hätte auch hiing Ping in Peking sehr
sehr gerne und ein paar andere hätten
das auch noch so gerne aber so ist es
nicht und er er sagt dann wir wir müssen
mal aufhören über diesen globalen Süden
ständig zu reden als ob es den so in der
Form wirklich gäbe so quasi wir der
reiche abgetakelte dekadente und
alternde reiche Norden und auf der
anderen Seite dieser diese jungen
aufstrebenden Länder des Südens die die
in Wahrheit sagt er einfach nur eine
gedankliche Konstruktion sind um uns
irgendwie mies fühlen zu lassen er sagt
im Süden liegen Australien und
Neuseeland das sind westliche
demokratische Länder
dann gibt es die demokratische sagen wir
Supermacht kommende Supermacht Indien es
gibt die aufstrebenden asiatischen
Tigerstaaten alle
areligiös Chinesisch geprägt aber
multikulturell z.B Singapur und so
weiter dann gibt es das islamisch
geprägte aber auch sehr multikulturelle
malayia es gibt das buddhistisch
geprägte Vietnam es gibt
die von Katholizismus geprägten Länder
Lateinamerikas und so weiter und so
weiter und er sagt das was sie gemeinsam
haben wenn man fragt da gibt es diesen
globalen Süden ja was haben diese Länder
mit China gemein das eben nicht
irgendwie aus einer wie soll man sagen
aus einer das aktuelle moderne China das
hat ja nicht dieses die die diese große
universale Idee aus dem das schöpft
sondern das ist ja ein Mischmasch
westlicher Ideen das ist Kapitalismus
mit ein bisschen Kommunismus das ist irg
Nationalismus das ist auch Imperialismus
ja das sind auch also was was ich meine
Imperialismus ist nicht im Westen
entstanden Imperialismus gab's bei alten
Römern und Imperialismus gab's bei kan
also das ist sozusagenind Universalien
das ist auch nicht westlich sondern das
ist etwas was es überall in der Welt
gibt aber es gibt einen Einwand niemand
behauptet der globale Süden wäre ein
neues Machtzentrum niemand behauptet der
globale Süden bildet einen Pol in der
multipolaren Weltordnung das sagt keiner
sondern man sagt es gibt ein eine
Veränderung der Kräfte das
Selbstbewusstsein damit fängt das ja mal
an gerade der afrikanischen Staaten ist
heute ein ganz anderes als es vor 20
oder 30 Jahren war und dass man sich
trauen kann nach Ende des Kalten Krieges
alla alakatmenü ja sich das rauszusuchen
mit dem die Allianz zu machen den
Chinesen von den Chinesen lässt man sich
Autobahnen bauen und den Franzosen
verkauft man Mineralien und so und dass
man das jetzt nicht mehr darum geht ob
das Ost oder West ist und wer welchenem
Block angehört das ist ein Faktum der
globale Süden ist ein Sammelbegriff aber
ist ein Sammelbegriff der den relativen
Bedeutungsverlust des Westens gegenüber
anderen Ländern in der Welt doch gut auf
den Punkt bringt abgesehen davon ist
auch der Westen kein so ganz konziser
Begriff undch das ist richtig ja also
historisch also Finnland ist historisch
sicherlich nicht der Westen ne wäre aber
für uns ein westliches Land Japan teilt
relativ viele Dinge im Hinblick auf
liberale Demokratie ist n überhaupt
nicht im Westen sondern im fernenosten
die Türkei gehört zum Westen dazu weil
sie Mitglied der NATO ist Punkt damit
endet aber auch schon ja die ganz große
Gemeinsamkeit s wieder bei Interessen ja
gehört gehört der die Schweiz eigentlich
zum Westen als nicht EU und nicht
natoitglied also auch das ist könnte man
jetzt sozusagen mit der gleichen
Rhetorik so auseinanderfriemeln ist aber
nicht der Punkt auf den es mir ankommt
dass ich das Gleichgewicht Gleichgewicht
ist lustig ne ich würde mal ich nehme
mal ein Begriff aus der Ökologie ja es
gibt der Josef reichholf der Ökologe und
vogelkenner der benutzt immer den
Begriff für die Natur stabile
gleichgewichtem und ich finde den kann
man wunderbar auf die Politik übertragen
ne ein Gleichgewicht hat es nie gegeben
es hat immer nur unterschiedliche
stabile Ungleichgewichte die für einige
Zeit hielten in der Welt gegeben und
dass wir jetzt eine Dynamik haben die
die Weltordnung verändert hin zu einer
multipolaren das ist für mich ein Faktum
das ist für mich auch das wird häufig
missverstanden weder ein
Glaubensbekenntnis noch eine bewusste
Entscheidung dafür oder dagegen so nach
dem Motto ich finde die multipolare Welt
tordnung nicht gut das war viel besser
wie das jetzt bislang unter der USA war
das soll so bleiben wie es ist als wenn
diese Option irgendwo auf dem Tisch läge
es bleibt überhaupt nichts wie es ist
und wir sind gerade in einer Zeit wo die
Dinge sich sehr schnell verändern ob wir
das wollen oder nicht wichtig ist dass
wir unser mindset entsprechend updaten
das heißt dass wir mit einer
Geisteshaltung die diese Veränderung
nicht klein redet sondern wirklich
versteht an die Sachen rangehen weil das
Schlimmste was uns passieren könnte ist
dass wir mit einer verkrusteten
Geisteshaltung an etwas festhalten also
dass wir an einem Kartenhaus weiterbauen
während die Erde Risse bekommt und das
ist meine Befürchtung zum Schluss
gefragt Richard auch noch mal auchag
nüchtern drauf geguckt ist das schlimm
ist das schlimm sozusagen wenn wir als
der Westen ja den als der wir uns fühlen
nach wie vor wenn wir nicht mehr die
Rolle spielen in der Welt von der wir
immer noch glauben dass uns irgendwie
zusteht wenn diese Art zu denken aufhört
ne wir also so der eine Blick diese
diese diese diese universale Idee wir
haben auch tendenziell sowieso immer
recht bei den Zweifel haben wir auch so
viel Geld dass wir uns
dass wir am Ende immer Recht haben
können wenn das nicht mehr so ist wenn
das endet ist das ist das ein Drama oder
ist das einfach nur eine andere Art die
Welt zu sehen mm spannende Frage die
hängt von der von mir nicht zu
beantwortenden Frage ab und ich kenne
auch keinen der sie gut beantworten kann
ob ähm der Abstieg bei uns unweigerlich
also der der Abstieg an politischer
Bedeutung global gesehen ne ob der auch
bedeutet dass wir uns ökonomisch
verschlechtern und zwar nicht nur
relativ s absolut absolut absteigen also
nicht relativ zu den anderen also
unseren Vorsprung verkleinern sondern
dass wir absolut absteigen und das ist
eine wahnsinnig schwierige Frage ja die
Linken haben ja früher immer diese
seltsame Theorie in die Welt gesetzt als
wäre Wirtschaft ein Nullsummenspiel das
heißt die Gewinne des einen sind die
Verluste des anderen so diese Idee jedem
Euro en steht irgendwo ein € G genau
wenn das so wäre dann hätte sich die
Wirtschaft seit der Steinzeit nicht
weiterentwickelt ja also das Brutto
Sozialprodukt der Länder ist seit der
Steinzeit enorm gestiegen und übrigens
seit dem Beginn des Kapitalismus noch
mal sehr sehr viel enormer ja das heißt
also es gibt heute viel viel viel mehr
zu verteilen als früher deswegen können
auch 8 Milliarden Menschen auf diesem
Planeten leben und davon die Hälfte
recht gut ja also so gesehen kann man ja
sagen wenn das weiterhin mehr und mehr
und mehr wird ja dann würde das ja nicht
bedeuten dass wir beim Ende
wohlstandseinbußen haben sondern die
anderen holen nur auf die anderen würden
nur aufholen aber durch die Technik und
durch die Wertschöpfung
würde die Gesamtsumme nicht kleiner
sondern größer so das ist die POS der
positive Blick kritisch dazu kann man
sagen dass alles im Zeitalter des
Klimawandels wo also Wachstum mit den
bisherigen Mitteln eigentlich nicht
weitergehen
darf das ist natürlich jetzt eine Sache
die die richtig Sand ins Getriebe streut
und das Ganze wirklich schwierig macht
das zweite ist begrenzthit der
Bodenschätze auch da gibt's zwei
Meinungen zu also die eine Meinung ist
wenn wir so weiter Maen und irgendwann
mal alles ausgebeutet haben dann ist
klar ja der wer den Zugang zu den
allerwichtigsten Ressourcen den Seltenen
Erden und so weiter hat der wird zu den
Gewinnern zählen und wer diesen Zugang
dann irgendwann verliert der guckt in
die Röhre da kann man wieder sagen wird
die Technik irgendwann soweit sein dass
wir bestimmte Stoffe eben nicht mehr
brauchen äh und stattdessen eben andere
nehmen können oder viel mehr synthetisch
herstellen und und und und und auch da
trübes Feld also ich wüsste nicht dass
es jemanden gibt der da die Zukunft
überschauen kann also wenn du jetzt
alles was ich bisher ins Feld geräumt
habe da abwägst und sagst also es könnte
h die Wirtschaftsleistung der Welt
könnte so stark ansteigen dass es bei
uns am Ende dann doch nicht dazu kommt
dass wir wohlstandseinbußen haben und
vielleicht sind die gibt es doch
deutlich mehr Ressourcen als wir bisher
in Betracht gezogen haben und ähm
vielleicht werden wir auch viele
Ressourcen nicht mehr angewiesen sein
dann könnte man zumindestens sagen es
ist denkbar dass in einer sich
verändernden Welt multipolare
Weltordnung Aufstieg vieler bislang
politisch unterrepräsentierter Länder in
denen Milliarden von Menschen leben eine
positive Zukunft zumindestens
vorstellbar ist also bleibt spannend
Richard dank dir sehr ja danke dir auch
Markus alles Liebe dir bis bald alles
Gute tschüss
tschüss
eine Produktion von mhoch2 und podstars
bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF